I'm Mitch Hedlund.
I'm the founder of Recycle Across America.
Recycle Across America is a non-profit organization that is developed...
...to simplify recycling in the US.
We've introduced a standardized labeling system...
...that is helping people become better recyclers out in public and it's making a difference.
For 2013, we are so honored to be chosen by Kiehl's again for a donation...
...that will allow us to give 65,000 pre-standardized labels to public schools throughout the US.
We are grateful to Alanis Morissette and Zach Quinto...
...for donating their time and their effort in bringing awareness to this important initiative.
If there's one thing that we can do for the environment, it is recycling.
Recycling impacts our land, our air, our water, our energy usage.
If we can improve our recycling rates to 75 percent in the US,...
...it will generate 1.5 million new jobs.
And it will be the environmental equivalent...
...of removing 55 million cars off US roads each year.
Recycle and be rewarded.